started as a visual artwork that was
about placing the wheelchair and in the
most unexpected environment I could
think about I started talking to
engineers and they was so convinced it
wouldn't work do you know it really
nearly put me off sue proved your
doubters wrong but why is making an
underwater wheelchair so hard the key to
scuba diving is being neutrally buoyant
to do that you need to balance the force
of gravity pulling you down and the
force of buoyancy pushing you up the
Sue's case she has a wheelchair which is
pulling her down to balance that out she
has a buoyancy control device by filling
these vessels with air she gets more
buoyant and goes up releasing it causes
her to go down now this serves a double
purpose this air also enables her to
breathe underwater
how does sue move forward through the
water sue needs to move through
three-dimensional space to do this she
has an electric propulsion system a
driver forwards but the system is
mounted at the bottom of the wheelchair
means it wants to pull the bottom of the
wheelchair forward while the top has the
drag of the water acting on it combined
so cause the wheelchair to tilts
backwards to stop this spin is attached
to large foot plate like fins over the
front of the wheelchair and this stops
the front from rising not only do these
plates keep her stable in the water but
they also make it possible for her to
navigate so with her feet she can press
down on the left pedal and move the left
plate turning her left likewise with the
right there's another fan in the back of
the chair and she's got five different
positions to choose from at the highest
position she could actually do a
backwards loop de loop at the lowest
position she'll do a forward roll there
is literally nothing I've done that
compares with Luke the looping in the
underwater wheelchair as the chair comes
down and round there's this incredible
force it's very visceral it did feel
amazing now that she's tamed the oceans
Sue's next project is a flying
wheelchair